ganz großbritannien scheint die luft
anzuhalten
das große königreich mit all seinen
stilbildenden kulturellen leistungen
bald ganz zurückgezogen auf seine schöne
einsame insel
wir bleiben entweder drin oder raus
wir werden dranbleiben dem lagen
definitiv wollen wie die schweizer über
unser eigenes schicksal bestimmen die
faust ist aus dem sack
dabei steht einiges auf dem spiegel rund
20 millionen euro fördergelder fließen
jährlich aus brüssel in die britische
kultur davon zwei drittel ans heimische
kino und film schaffen aber auch große
kulturhäuser mit weltruf profitieren
ändern
wie das wall street in london smarten
hier gastieren regelmäßig international
renommierte tanzformationen
wir treffen den künstlerischen direktor
ist dass poldi der ausstieg aus der eu
für ihn ein höchst ungemütliche szenario
zuallererst würden wir alle europäischen
gelder verlieren wir sind bei zwei eu
projekten arbeiten
es sind ungefähr 500.000 euro über fünf
jahre
das ist eine beachtliche summe der
praxis der gelbe probleme für all die
leute die für einen auftritt zu uns
kommt gleiches gilt für unsere ausland
gastspiele zumindest in der eurozone war
das bisher alles sehr unkompliziert was
arbeitsbewilligungen und visa betrifft
wer weiß wie sich das entwickeln könnte
kommt es ganz schlimm dann kriegen wir
eine extra große ladung bürokratie
verflixt nochmal so treibt es uns
geradewegs in die isolation schreibt die
britische kultur welt fast unisono
essence damien hirst und viele weitere
große namen befürworter eines ausstiegs
finden sich da keine mit eigens
erstellten kunstwerke rufen sie auch zum
verbleib in der eu ob sie damit die
empfänger erreichen
diesen gewitzten menschen aus südengland
könnte das vielleicht gelingen we have
only watch over betonen sie eine
anspielung auf die engen bande die
großbritannien mit dem kontinent pflegt
da drin ist frankreich wir müssen
zusammenbleiben
wir haben nur ein anderer steht fürs
bleiben wir müssen bleiben den mann
hinter dieser kunstaktion wollen wir
unbedingt treffen
es ist patrick prell seit er mit seiner
schwester roboter künstlerisch tätig war
nennt das sich bot entry wörter smith er
erzählt uns aus welcher küche dieser
arbeit stand meine mutter sagte dass sie
ist 90 und es geht ihr nicht mehr ob sie
hatte einen schlaganfall an den zweiten
weltkrieg erinnert sie sich besser als
an ihre letzte tasse tee auf dem zweiten
weltkrieg kommt sie immer wieder zu
sprechen
wir redeten neulich über europa und ich
sagte ihr dass es da eine abstimmung
gäbe da meinte sie
warum er denn im streit sein wir hätten
doch nur einander
ich fand das eine entzückende und
berührende aussage über unseren umgang
mit der wir müssen miteinander hand
betreiben miteinander sprechen und zu
recht kommt mit dem migrationsströmen
das ist das große problem im moment aber
lösungen finden nur im gespräch und
übereinkommen nicht mit mauern barrieren
grenzen und sollen steigen wir aus der
eu aus dann bringt schottland gleich am
freitag die unabhängigkeit frage erneut
auf den tisch das friedensabkommen in
nordirland dass dort alles zusammenhält
den bewaffneten konflikt verhindert wird
platzen weil das land nicht mehr in der
eu ist wales wird nicht mehr länger die
englische herrschaft rücken
noch unzufriedener werden und gehe was
unabhängig würde wäre kein vereinigtes
königreich mehr
deshalb zieht ihren exit gegner den
geistigen vater eines vereinten europas
ob sir winston churchill tatsächlich
noch heute sagen würde
die briten gehen nicht raus der gute
zweck heiligt fast alle mittel wie auch
der walliser musiker graf dies beweist
die grüße
das erste liebeslied für die union und
ihre vorzüge mit der hoffnung damit beim
funk auf wohlgefallen zu stoßen
aber sein ich hoffe dass die leute sich
nicht durchringen und einsehen dass sich
die beziehung zur eu durchaus verändern
soll
dass wir aber in dieser diskussion mit
dabei sein sollten und nicht draußen
ich bin letztlich optimistisch und
glaube die briten werden bleiben dort
wunschdenken
das mag wunschdenken sein am donnerstag
werden wir es sehen
oh mein gott ich hoffe so sehr dass wir
für den verbleib stimmen wenn wir
rausgehen wäre das erschütternd
den schicksalswahl der briten vor augen
es droht ein erwachen mit deftigem katar